[MUSIC PLAYING]
PRESENTER: I am
pleased to welcome
to the platform the
Honorable Walter L. Sullivan,
Mayor of the city of
Cambridge, and Mr. William R.
Hewlett, Vice Chairman of
the board of Hewlett-Packard
company.
Mr. Hewlett will now give
the commencement address.
[APPLAUSE]
WILLIAM R. HEWLETT: I see I
brought my California weather
with me.
I apologize.
Graduating class of
1986, relatives, faculty,
and friends, it's a
very great pleasure
to be with you this
morning, because it's
exactly 50 years since I
walked across the stage at MIT
and I was given of a
piece of paper that
said I was a Master of Science.
In those 50 years, I have
been intimately associated
with the creative
process that is
so important to our modern
high technology, culture.
I felt that it might be
appropriate, therefore,
to share with you some
random thoughts on creativity
and its importance
in today's society.
When I was preparing
this address,
I happened to ask Chuck House,
who heads our engineering
productivity department what
he thought about creativity.
With a twinkle in
his eye, Chuck said,
creativity is what screws
up my engineering program.
[LAUGHTER]
Unfortunately, there is much
truth in that statement.
Thomas Edison is alleged to have
remarked about his laboratory,
there ain't no
rules around here,
we're trying to
accomplish something.
I cite these two comments,
because they say a great deal
about the creative process.
It works best when it
is not too structured,
but it must, in the long run,
be tamed, harnessed, and hitched
to the wagon of man's needs.
First, let me set a
background to this country's
renewed interest in
innovation and creativity.
By 1983, it was
increasingly evident
that we were losing the
competitive edge that
for so long had characterized
the American economy.
To better understand
this problem,
President Reagan created
a high level commission
of distinguished business
leaders and educators
to review means of increasing
the long term competitiveness
of the United States
industry at home and abroad
with particular emphasis
on high technology.
After an in-depth
study, the commission
concluded they were not meeting
the competitive challenge
well enough.
It stated, our ability to
compete in world markets
is eroding.
Growth and US productivity
lags far behind that
of our foreign competitors.
Real hourly compensation
for our workforce
is no longer improving.
US leadership and world
trade is declining.
Finally, free tax rate of
return on assets invested
in manufacturing
discourages investment
in this vital core
of our economy.
One of the commission's
primary recommendations
was to create, apply,
and protect technology.
Innovation spurs new industries
and revise mature ones.
Technological advances lead
to improved productivity,
an essential ingredient
of our standard of living.
In essence, this
recommendation was twofold--
to create technology and
to improve productivity.
How do I define creativity?
Nobel Prize winner
Szent-Gyorgyi provided
a good working
definition when he said,
discovery consists of looking at
the same thing as everyone else
and thinking something
quite different.
That's a good enough
summary to cover much
of what I wish to comment on.
The trouble is that
creativity is really
a poly-faceted discipline.
Trying to describe
it in detail reminds
me of the story of the
three blind men who
attempted to describe
an elephant solely
by their sense of feel.
One explored the
trunk, one discovered
the tusks, the
third investigated
the animal's enormous feet.
But none really
had a good picture
of what the whole
animal looked like.
I would like to describe
my elephant, creativity,
as I've had a chance to
observe it over these years.
First, let me make one general
comment about creative people.
Education is not a [INAUDIBLE]
known for being creative.
A case at point is that of the
most successful engineer who
worked for us for many years.
Despite the fact
that he had only
completed one year
of college, he
was one of the most creative
people I have known.
You could present Larry with
the most difficult problem,
and he would come up with
really ingenious solutions.
He had the ability to isolate
the essentials of the problem
and tackle it with vigor.
It was such a pleasure to
talk to him about his work.
He just bubbled over
with enthusiasm.
Many of his ideas are still
incorporated in products
we are currently manufacturing.
It is very difficult to
spot a creative individual
just by looking at a resume.
Psychologists can't
even agree on how
to measure this characteristic,
let alone predict
who will display it.
Establishing an environment that
fosters creativity and observe
those who flourish is
probably the best way
of finding this elusive talent.
I would like to distinguish
between two different kinds
of creativity.
One is spontaneous in
which an individual
sees a complete and
elegant solution
to an interesting problem.
The other I call
creativity on demand
in which specific objectives are
established that must be met,
both a great deal of
flexibility and how
the results are to be achieved.
Both types of
successful innovators
share many traits in common.
Creative people have an abiding
curiosity and an insatiable
desire to learn how
and why things work.
They take nothing for granted.
They are interested
in things around them
and tend to stow away bits
and pieces of information
in their mind for future use.
And they have a great ability
to mobilize their thinking
and experiences for use
in solving a new problem.
Problems, however,
are rarely solved
on the spur of the moment.
They must be organized
and dissected,
then key issues
isolated and defined.
A period of [INAUDIBLE]
then sets in, during which
these issues are mulled over.
You put them in your mind, and
consciously or unconsciously,
you work at them at odd hours
of day or night, even at work.
It is somewhat
analogous to trying
to place a name on the face of
someone that you've met before.
Often, the solution
to the problem
comes to you much the same
way that you eventually
recall the name.
There is a subclass of
individuals that not only have
the ability to see
things around them,
but also to note that which
differs from the norm.
A good example is
Sir Arthur Fleming,
who discovered penicillin.
His story is familiar
to many of you.
He noted that when a mold
had landed on a culture disk
with a colony of
Staphylococci, the colonies
adjacent to the
mold were killed.
Many other scientists may
have had the same problem,
but it simply passed by.
In fact, Fleming
himself remembered
such a previous occurrence.
But this time, he
became more interested
and concluded the mold must
have secreted something
that was toxic to the bacteria,
and if so that something might
be beneficial in the
treatment of human infection.
Thus, the drug
penicillin was born.
I have observed the
same creative phenomena
and the same questioning
minds a number of times.
A few years ago, a young British
engineer who was working for us
was investigating
the characteristics
of a new semiconductor device.
In all the tests, it performed
basically as expected.
But Frank noted
that there seemed
to be an excess of noise
in his measurement.
He completed his project
but was still curious.
He decided to look into the
source of his excess noise.
With the aid of a newly
developed measuring technique,
he discovered that the noise
was, in fact, a very high order
harmonic train, essentially an
electrical analogy of a water
hammer.
This proved to be a
very important discovery
for certain nanosecond
measurements.
In fact, it made practical
the very technology
that was used to identify it.
Intellectual curiosity is a
great source of creativity.
An example is that demonstrated
by Nobel Prize winner Luis
Alvarez, a longtime
member of our board.
While visiting Egypt, Luis
became interested in the fact
that no major
burial chambers have
been found in the
periods of Khefren
and began to muse about
how one might determine
if such a chamber did exist.
Luis was familiar
with cosmic rays
and knew they might be suitable
for X-raying the pyramid.
Careful investigation
led him to the conclusion
that, if he had been asked
to design a proper radiation
source for this
purpose, it would
have been the mu meson,
an important component
of cosmic rays that
exactly fitted the need.
An added bonus was the
fact that under the pyramid
was a chamber that
extended the full length
of the base, in which he
could locate his film--
that is, a series
of detectors that
could measure the
strength of the mu meson
as well as the
direction of arrival.
With these thoughts
in mind, he went
to the chancellor
of US Berkeley, who
on the basis of Luis'
analysis provided
a small amount of money to
carry out the experiment.
I mention this, because it
is a good example of how
a little support can
encourage a creative person.
The study was not
a normal function
of a physics department, nor
was financing of it easy.
It was just a
fascinating subject
the chancellor thought might add
to man's knowledge of the past.
Luis received the
enthusiastic support
of the Egyptian government, and
the experiment in due course
took place.
No chamber was discovered.
Yet the experiment
was successful,
because Luis was able to
prove beyond doubt that there
was no major chamber
in the pyramid.
Another example is
that of an HP scientist
who was a specialist in
designing quartz crystals used
for generating extremely
accurate time standards.
The accuracy of such
reference crystals
is very sensitive to
change in temperature
and mechanical force.
Much of the existing
technology used
to stabilize these
crystals has to do
with minimizing the effect
of these two variables.
Don took the opposite view.
He thought, why not use
the intrinsic sensitivity
of temperature as a way to
produce a digital thermometer?
Normally, the
frequency change is not
a linear function
of temperature,
but Don devised a technique
to linearize this relationship
to about a tenth of a degree
over a range from minus 40
to 200 degrees centigrade and
with the resolution of about
a ten thousandth of a degree.
A major advantage
of this technique,
other than that
that are obvious,
was that the sensing
element could
be located as far as 10,000 feet
from the measuring instrument
with no loss of accuracy.
In a similar fashion, he
produced a quartz transducer
that operated at pressures up
to 10,000 pounds per square inch
with an accuracy of
about a twentieth
of a pound per square inch
and a resolution of about
a thousandth of a BSI.
This device has been
used extensively
in oceanographic studies and
for measuring differential
pressures in oil fields
to determine the best
pumping strategy.
Basically, I've been talking
about creativity applied
to research type situations.
Now, let me turn
to the development
phase, where creativity on
demand is the usual mode.
Here, creativity's role
is slightly different.
There is now a clearly
defined objective,
and the job is to find
a way to meet this goal.
This is the type of
creativity about which
much has been written, primarily
because techniques to stimulate
and enhance it are well known.
One book on this subject
I greatly enjoyed
was Conceptual Blockbusting
by James L. Adams.
His title suggests
that we all suffer
from mental blocks that stand
in the way of solving problems
at hand.
These might be emotional
blocks, such as fear
of failure, frustration, or too
much or too little motivation.
They may be perceptual
blocks, such as using
incorrect information
or the wrong method
or not all your senses.
Quite often, they are cultural
blocks, which sometimes
can be the hardest to overcome.
I think this is an area in
which younger people have
a tremendous advantage,
since, as you well know,
they have an enduring habit of
always questioning past wisdom
and authority.
They say to themselves,
there must be a better way.
99 times out of
100, they discover
that existing traditional
ways are the best.
But it is that 1% that counts.
This is how progress is made.
A wonderful example
of the desire
to break from the rigid
traditions of the past
may be that of the French
impressionist painters
during the latter part
of the 19th century.
The most important works
of these painters had been
excluded from the Salon, held
in Paris nearly every year under
the auspices of Les
Académie des Beaux-Arts.
The Salon juries
refused their work,
because they did not
follow the traditions
of the academic schools.
Finally in 1874, the
impressionists, several of them
in their 20s and
30s, banded together
to share the cost of exhibiting
their own controversial works.
And a series of eight of
these impressionistic exhibits
were held.
And by 1886, the
impressionist school
was well established
and recognized.
But now to return to the
more mundane world of R&D.
Projects do not always progress
at a steady uniform rate.
Sometimes, progress is stymied
by very difficult problems.
The problem might be overcome
by clear technical breakthrough.
But more often than
not, it is bypassed
with a compromised solution
I like to call a hot patch.
If there are too many
of these hot patches,
you probably will wind up
with a very clumsy solution
to the problem.
My company has often employed
retired engineers or scientists
on a part time consulting base.
One such was Harald Friis of
Bell Telephone Laboratories.
I am sure that some of
the electrical engineers
in the audience are familiar
with his book on antenna
design.
Harald and his wife would come
to California during the winter
months and spend time in and
around Palo Alto Harald enjoyed
visiting with our engineers
in the laboratories.
Frankly, he didn't know
beans about modern transistor
circuitry, but he knew how to
think about the development
process, and he loved to
work with the engineers who
felt they had reached a
dead end on a project.
He would get them to step back
and view their work as a whole.
He would ask, what are
you really trying to do?
Are you on the right
track, or do you
feel you have too
many hot patches?
Or are you really
on the wrong track
and need to make a fresh start?
This can be one of the toughest
decisions a development
engineer may have to make.
Harald was just wonderful in
helping young engineers reach
this critical decision.
He had a way of making a person
see things in perspective,
and engineers just loved him.
We always try to encourage
this kind of interaction
in our laboratories
between generations,
because experienced
engineers can
be very helpful in the
development process.
In this exchange of
ideas, I have often
seen younger researchers
learn new ways to harness
the use of their instincts.
In practice,
spontaneous creativity
and normal development process
are often intertwined and may,
in fact, seem to conflict.
Witness Chuck House's
comments referred
to earlier, there is a time
and a place for creativity,
but in the development
process timing sometimes
outweighs innovation.
It all comes back
to the question
of how often you can change
course and still make forward
progress.
I remember when we were
trying to bring out
our first scientific
desktop calculator.
Integrated circuits were
just being introduced.
And we had to decide whether to
delay the entry of the project,
so that we might use
integrated circuits,
or go ahead and introduce it
with a primitive but proven
read-only memory device.
We chose the latter.
Timing was a dominant factor and
not the nicest to the solution.
I have talked enough about
creativity in the R&D phase.
Now, let's look
at how creativity
can help increase productivity
and improve quality.
This challenge is clearly
defined by the findings
of the President's commission.
We need the same creative
effort in the production process
that we now lavish on
the development phase.
We must start by having
productivity and quality
as stated objectives of the
research and development
program.
Productivity must be
designed under a project,
not added at a later date.
Quality cannot be inspected in.
There was already a great deal
of technology readily available
that can be used to improve
quality and manufacturability
of a product.
In many cases, however,
the US industries
have not taken advantage of this
knowledge, although much of it
originated in the United States.
We need new ideas and new
leadership in this quest.
Here, the universities have
a very real responsibility.
I don't mean that
they should go back
to teaching forge, foundry,
and machine shop, subjects
that I had to take as
an engineering student.
But our universities
do need to provide
a theoretical base for
quality and efficiency
in the manufacturing process.
I am delighted to learn
that this trend is already
underway at this institution.
But after all, what
else would you expect.
I hope I've made it
clear that creativity
will play a vital and critical
role in our increasingly
high tech society.
Our company president, John
Young, put it this way.
Creativity is the only American
competitive advantage left.
Industry is going to have to
make some dramatic changes
in how it views the importance
of research and development
programs and the necessity
of increasing productivity.
Change never comes easy.
There's comfort in
safety and tradition.
But change must come
no matter how painful
or how expensive it may be.
From your standpoint,
this situation
is anything but bleak.
Personal advancement
in a static company
or a static industry can be slow
and difficult. Change, however,
opens cracks in those
monolithic structures.
It presents a period
of great opportunity,
for this is the time when
the best and the most
creative minds we
sought out and placed
in positions of responsibility.
In the high tech
field, top leadership
was always looking for good
minds, high energy levels,
and willingness to
accept responsibility.
In fact, our company is so
dependent upon creativity
that we're still emphasizing
the recruitment of engineering
graduates, even though there
is a freezing hire in effect
for the rest of the company.
It may turn out that the present
period will be looked back
upon as one of
unprecedented opportunity
for a scientifically minded.
You are in a unique
position to take
advantage of this situation.
Good luck.
I wish you success, happiness,
and great bursts of creativity
in all of your endeavors.
[APPLAUSE]